- What a gentlemen.
Oh my gosh, you're like even
more handsome in real life.
- Oh, thank you.
- Just saying.
Just saying.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- I'm a huge, huge fan.
So I have to start with I love
"The Guardians of the Galaxy."
- Right.
- So you were the Pursuer,
Korath the Pursuer.
So is it true that you wanted
do the movie for your son?
I would've wanted to do it just to do it.
- Right, I mean-
- Yeah.
It's "Guardians of the Galaxy"
- I wanted to do it just to do it,
but it's in reference to something
that happened with my son.
That from the day he was born,
and some of the films
and sort of animations
that he's seen were mostly
"Spider-Man," you know,
"Batman," and so on and over time,
one day he just blurted out this idea
that he wished he were white
in order to climb walls like Spider-Man,
and so that really
shocked me and I thought
he has never seen a
superhero looking like him.
See what I mean?
And so for him, over time,
the understanding is we-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That looks like don't have the ability
to climb walls like Spider-Man,
and so I was eager to look
for some content online
that could redeem that.
- You got two!
- And come to find out, during that time,
I had done a voiceover
for "Black Panther,"
and I completely forgot about it
so as I was searching and that came up,
and I played it for him.
Wait a minute, he's hearing the voice
and he's like, "Baba, is that you?"
- You're like, yes it is.
- So that's one of the reasons
why I was really drawn
to the idea of being-
- I love that.
It is important for them to see
what they can be or achieve.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, I love that it's not just one,
like "Guardians of the Galaxy,"
There's also "Shazam."
It's like you're in two.
(audience cheers)
That's amazing.
- And "Shazam," luckily "Shazam,"
it really speaks of the diversity,
the idea of diversity.
- And inclusion.
Even with the powers.
Absolutely.
- Yeah.
I know we're gonna get to that.
I loved it.
So okay so speaking of kiddos though,
you just announced that
you and your girlfriend,
you're having a baby, right?
Congrats.
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- I mean, here's the thing.
I have a six
and eight year old.
- Me and my fiance, yes.
- Your fiance.
Oh, congratulations.
I'm so sorry, I thought it was girlfriend.
Next level, okay.
- Yes, the next level indeed.
- I like it.
- Yes, we are expecting
another baby.
- [Kelly] A little baby.
- Yes.
- So what are you most excited
about a new little baby?
I love the smell.
- Well, that's a hard question
because-
- And then the skin on skin, but go ahead.
- When you ask me that,
the first thing I'm drawn to speak about
it's the lack of sleep.
- Yeah. No.
Okay, that was my next question.
What are you most not excited about?
- Right. That.
- You don't get sleep.
- You don't get any sleep at all,
but I'm really excited about
really creating a foundation
which he could leverage
himself, you know, growing up.
It's important.
(audience applauds)
- I think it's cool too.
Like, I have friends that
have kids of all ages, right?
And they have at different points in life,
and I had kids later in life
compared to where I'm from.
They all like have babies
right out of high school
usually where I'm from.
- Me too.
- So yeah, I was late, I was in my 30s.
So I love that I was older.
I felt like I had a different mindset,
and I felt like I was more
responsible, more selfless,
all those things that-
- More mature, yeah.
- Yeah. More mature.
So do you feel like it's kind of
a different time to have a kid, right?
So it's like, I don't know.
Later in life I feel like it's better.
- Yeah, very much so.
I think, you know, for men in general,
you need to at least
be 35, 40, to you know-
- Yeah, spread the word.
- Really, we're not much of
a man until we've achieved
some of the challenges
that young men would face.
You know, we're not much of a man.
And so-
- But I think women too,
it's better later in life, I think.
- And women too, it's a little bit better.
- You get to experience life
in your 20s and really know
what you're talking about.
- You get to experience,
you get to travel.
Yes. Absolutely.
- Yeah, I'm excited for y'all.
Well, we heard so we
got you a little gift.
So this is for-
- Oh, sweet.
- So there's a little onesie
and it says there, life
would suck without you.
That's right, that's what we did.
Yup, yup, yup, and then that's to keep
your little one warm and a bunny.
And then this is to
keep you warm and happy.
That's Kosta Browne.
That's a real good wine.
- Yes. Absolutely.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome in advance.
- Absolutely. Thank you.
- You're gonna use that at night. (laughs)
When you're not sleeping.
- I'm using it right away.
- I know. I love wine.
So wait, you're originally
from Benin, right?
West Africa?
- Benin Republic, West Africa.
I had a-
- [Kelly] Was it hard to adjust?
- You kidding me?
- Yeah, I'm from Texas
and it was hard for me
to adjust here.
- Benin Republic so I was
sent to Europe, to France
to better my education, and it's there
that I come to learn about movies.
You know, more about movies in general,
but really about superhero
movies, and so on and so forth.
So I mean, my early days
of interaction with films
came from a very young
age where every Wednesday
we had off from school.
So every Wednesday, all children
and all kids from school,
I mean, would be off from
school and everybody,
there's only one theater in that city.
- [Kelly] Oh, so you'd all get together.
- And so we all get together
and go to the movie theater,
and so you have the whole week
to collect detergent packages
that you would recycle, and
that would give you a ticket to-
- Oh, that's incredible.
- And so it was incredible,
and so but the theater will be so filled
because imagine we're
talking about the capital.
There's only one movie theater there,
which was called Vogue at the time.
- Who has the responsibility
of picking that movie for everyone?
- Well, you know, but it was interesting
because the theater would be so filled
all the way to the bathroom,
all the way to the outside, to the walls,
people, kids will be climbing walls
to just hear the sound
of the film playing.
And generally those film playing were-
- It's magical.
- It was magical for us.
Those films were like Gary
Cooper, you know, cowboy.
And all we could hear the
sound of the gun going off and-
- Horses, all the stuff.
- Shoes with the spurs, you know?
- You're like, Americans are crazy.
- But it was uplifting for us,
and it was really a
different world, you know?
- That's super magical.
- That was absolutely magical for us.
So that was my awakening to-
- I love that.
- To movies.
And so when I got to Europe
and understood more about television,
seeing television, and seeing documentary
and so on and so forth,
so that's how I became more in love
with the idea of being part of, you know,
trying to do this as a career.
- Yeah, 'cause it seems so magical.
That's why I wanted to be a part of it.
His new movie is "Shazam:
Fury of the Gods."
So I love the movie.
Could you explain your character
and kind of what drew you to the role?
- This idea of dealing with magic,
and playing an ancient wizard,
and the country I come
from, Benin Republic,
is a place where magic and this idea
of the forces of nature, we're very much
very connected to that.
- Which is real. Yeah.
- And through this idea
of this way of life
that's called voodoo.
And voodoo over time had
suffered tremendous defamation.
The notion is that this is a evil doing,
evil way of practicing some
sort of like religious.
- Well, that's a big bummer.
- It sure is a big bummer,
but it was due to slavery.
I've come to find out
when I finally decided
because I wanted to understand
why there was such a bad name.
- Like negative connotation.
- Negative connotation about voodoo,
and so I wanted to do
a documentary about it
because again, I come from a country
in which, you know, now
every January 10th, it's
a national celebration
throughout the country.
And even people from various
places in the diaspora
meaning Cuba, Dominican Republic, Brazil,
they travel all the way
to Benin to celebrate.
- Wow, so the documentary
will kind of explain
what it really is, right?
- I tried, and I think this is one of
the most challenging things
I ever came trying to realize,
and they don't really
like to talk about it.
- God, I can't wait to
see this documentary.
What's it called again?
- "In Search of Spirit,
In Search of Voodoo."
- In Search of Spirit,
Okay. Awesome.